[Music]
what's up everybody welcome Jimmy Tosi
podcast
it is Thursday Thursday we had to record
a bunch of episodes in advance because
we have left Los Angeles by you lizards
come we're gone forever
we're in route route to the desert where
we will be making this podcast full-time
because of your support David Pakman is
on the show host of the David Pakman
show he's so [ __ ] smart and wonderful
and great and I have a million things I
want to talk to him about which I will
be doing very shortly on the Skype we of
course are not sponsored by Skype we
don't have any sponsors we feel like
it's it's a little hard to to cover war
crimes or to cover Hey are you uh are
you an immigrant child being held in a
tiny cage and being denied soap and
towels and you want to write a letter
begging for help
well I'll tell you how to stamp that
letter stamps calm are you a tiny
immigrant child being held in a cage and
sleeping on a dirty floor you know that
tiny child would rather be sleeping on a
Casper mattress are you a tiny child who
would love to be an entrepreneur using a
website like Squarespace but instead
you're being de forcibly detained by the
US government the greatest country in
the world
Squarespace com use promo code help me
get me the [ __ ] out of here I'm just a
kid on a cage squarespace.com okay
before we get the david pacman i want to
shout out this is the coolest thing that
could have happened before we left la
because it would be so [ __ ] easy to
be a screaming liberal or a screaming
conservative we would get so much more
traffic so much more money but we're
sticking to our principles we're trying
not to be [ __ ] on this show and i
feel like we were rewarded like producer
girlfriend Emma and I celebrated all
night when we got this
we have a new $50 a month member holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
huge IDI right but then add writes this
email Jamie I know you would be really
happy to hear that you have another $50
per month from a very liberal
twenty-something super cool chick
I mean think girl with the dragon tattoo
only American so there aren't any weird
symbols over anything I write I know
this would make you happy but
unfortunately for you I'm another older
white guy it gets worse I'm conservative
even worse I'm in the military sorry I
listened to your show because while I
don't always agree with you I agree with
your approach I enjoy being on the
journey with you as you from political
life philosophy of your own here's my
ask stay honest and don't pander to me
or any other conservative in return I
promise that even if you pissed me off
I'll keep my donation going for at least
a year good luck on your new life with
girlfriend producer Emma I wish you both
the best signed I'm nicknaming you ed
with the Dragon Tattoo that is the
coolest email especially the ask don't
pander to me you're still gonna get my
money I've had liberals cancel because
they've disagreed with something I've
said so this is just [ __ ] awesome
it's what we're trying to build on the
show I love man I don't agree with
anything you say but I like you here's
some money to keep the lights on and to
keep the show growing that's [ __ ]
really really cool so thank you ed with
the Dragon Tattoo if you guys want to
support the show as well you can go to
patreon.com/scishow steam podcast for as
little as five dollars a month you can
keep the conversation going on twitter
at me at Jamie kills teen you come right
into the show all that good stuff but
the best way to support the show is
patreon.com slash Jamie Coulson podcast
thank you guys for everything now I
present to you the host of the David
Pakman show which all of you should
check out on iTunes you follow my
Twitter Dee Pakman
hey how's it going man here thank you so
much for doing this
oh no problem I I feel like me and you
you probably started before me but I
feel like we were kind of we could have
been friends and something happened I
assumed it was my fault but we were in
like kind of the same new liberal
podcaster world like a decade ago like
it was you were on email chains that's
how I found your email it was like me
you J from best of the left and when I
the whole like started this [ __ ]
together yep yeah I actually saw J
pretty recently and that rings a bell I
mean that totally sounds like how we
would have been linked up years ago but
then I don't know why so here's my guess
which I'm not happy about
I assume cuz like my old show was like
trying to be like the the rebel show and
I think I was just secretly jealous
where I'm like who's that [ __ ]
good-looking guy who's really articulate
and well-spoken well I'm trying to tell
dick jokes and like tell bush to suck my
[ __ ] and instead of reaching out and
becoming friends with you I just like
silently pretended you weren't on those
email Thanks well that's it's it's it
takes a big person to admit that
although I would I would question
whether that was exactly what was going
on but it makes for a good story anyway
it does make for a good story but here's
what's cool and this is why I wanted you
on the show
so we've both been on Joe Rogan show and
which means we've both had good
conversations with Joe Rogan then gotten
home had our liberal fans yell at us
that we talked to someone on the whole
tray and then had his conservative fans
call us like cuck snowflakes yeah that's
basically how it went down it is right
okay and but what I what I didn't know
about you and I've only recently started
listening to your podcast which I'm a
fan of now but what I didn't know and
here's where I'm kind of glad we connect
and now that we both have this in common
and what I want to talk to you about
first is that we both
while still being very liberal have
conservative fans and have more moderate
fans I know my trajectory and how that
happened with me but how did that happen
with you and why do you think that's
actually kind of cool and important
because I feel like a lot of people on
the Left get pissed off if you're even
talking to conservatives well I don't
know that my conservative or moderate
following is actually that big I mean I
know anecdotally that I have some and
even some paid subscribers because
unless they're lying I mean they tell me
what their views are and they say even
if they don't agree with my conclusions
you know they still want to support the
work I'm doing because they think that
in the sort of marketplace of ideas at
least I'm coming to it with a
progressive perspective that is genuine
and in good faith informed by what I
claim that it's informed by rather than
sort of playing politics in the way that
I think some people don't like but I
actually don't think that I have any
really significant moderate or
conservative following of beyond you
know anecdotal one I think there's
definitely lots of right wingers that
regularly comment on my content and it's
mostly negative comments and the last
sense like there is an audience but I
don't know that they really consider
themselves like my core supporters in
any serious way but I would say having
paid I mean you know how small the
percentages of listeners to paid
supporters having paid supporters does
mean you are doing something to at least
not drive them away so let me maybe let
me reframe the conversation to allow you
to stay humble to reframe the
conversation I never wanted to call
myself a moderate because I feel like
moderate and I feel like even when you
talk about compromise people visualize
sort of the worst of the Democrat you
know like a sort of like Joe Lieberman
type or Chuck Schumer type compromising
with like a slimy Republican and they
both come together to [ __ ] over
everybody else right but I do think that
it is important and there is kind of a
new group of people who at the very
aren't willing to like on my old show if
I had someone who was like a man I don't
agree with you but like I would
conservative that voted for Bush I'm
gonna be like here's your [ __ ] money
back you bigot and I wouldn't have even
listened to them but I do think it's
important and you go hard after
Republicans on your show so I don't
think you're pandering to them or you're
on the center-right but I do think that
there is something important about being
able to have a conversation that's not
going to drive conservatives away
especially if your goal is present
liberal ideas definitely yeah and I
regularly engage with right-wing guests
and right-wing callers I mean we don't
screen calls in the sense that anybody
who wants to get on can get on and their
politics can be anything and they can
ask me anything that they want obviously
if they're trolling me I'll just hang up
on them if I don't want to talk to them
but in that sense I have no problem
engaging with people that have whatever
political perspective I mean I do think
that when we talk about compromise it's
like you can't actually compromise with
crazy people and some of them I would
argue you know I'm all about the
marketplace of ideas but I said this on
the Rogen program some ideas are just so
extreme that there's no serious way to
kind of like include them in figuring
out what it is that you should do on any
particular issue and I'm not afraid to
say that I mean I don't think anybody
should be silenced if they want to make
a youtube channel or have a podcast and
say they're crazy piece by all means do
it but when the adults in the room have
to figure out serious stuff at a certain
point you've got to draw a line as to
like what's allowed to even be be
seriously considered in terms of how we
want to figure out the problems that
we're facing right now yes and I feel
like there are some issues that I and no
one should ever compromise on like I
remember when citizen radio was kind of
like peak popular and we were taking
meetings we were taking meetings look
like MTV and it was always it was always
like the low-level people like the new
fresh out of college people who like
loved the show like I remember I walked
into MTV in our first meeting they had
like the nation on like their coffee
table like I don't know if they just
brought it in because like we were
coming in
and you know we're talking about like no
child like what if we get Noam Chomsky
on MTV and that once we got to like the
VP's it was very much like you have to
show both sides which I always hated
hearing that your kids in my head it was
like there's no other side to homophobia
there's no other side to racism like if
you have Martin Luther King on you
wouldn't also have to balance it out by
having the Klan on is I think something
we said in the meeting but I feel like
nowadays we've kind of gone in the
extreme other direction where I've had a
ton of conservatives write in and be
like hey just you know like I'm cool
with gay people and I am kind of liberal
on this yet issue and when you have
people saying that if you even talk to
like a Joe Rogan or you talk to a
conservative and you've interviewed a
lot of way more right-wing people that
you're by giving them a platform you're
essentially siding with that yeah I
completely reject that of course and it
all matters what matters is what kind of
a platform are you giving them are you
saying take 15 minutes say whatever you
want I'll just sit here and shut up it's
yeah I would never do that and that is a
major major problem if what you're doing
is saying I think your ideas are
dangerous and I'm going to let you
present them without interrupting you
and then I will tell you why I think
that they're wrong okay now we're
talking and I think we're doing
something valuable right do you find
yourself I see you do it sometimes how
do you balance on Twitter cuz what I
again what I love about your show from
what I've heard recently is talking
about ideas and concepts and not putting
teams above I talked about this on the
show a lot like not putting partisanship
like above principles right and I think
that's really important how do you I
also feel like on Twitter and on social
media you're kind of rewarded the most
for just attacking people right like
attacking other talk show hosts
attacking other people when your tribe
you know the liberals always got accused
of like infighting
how do you balance that do you think
that do you think if some of it is just
would you rather talk about ideas do you
you know like sometimes when I try to
describe a Twitter fight that's
happening in like the progressive world
to a friend of mine that's not on
Twitter they're like who the [ __ ] are
any of these people and I Hanna and I
asked myself like Oh does does the
Twitter liberal verse even matter when
people are trying to like survive yeah
more on the weekends and like starting
that earlier earlier like halfway
through the day on Friday or like Friday
morning and the most refreshing
revelation is it just doesn't really
matter like the real world and Twitter
have an overlap but at the same time
it's not a total overlap and a lot of
what is happening and these would seem
like really important it's sort of like
in high school everything seemed like
wow this is going to basically determine
my entire life as info like oh wow a lot
of that stuff just really did not matter
in any way with social media exactly the
jock isn't still coming to kick my ass
at the age of 37 I it was so funny I
want to talk to you cuz I actually
interviewed Dave Rubin last week which I
know you guys had many of disagreements
and I wanted I wanted to talk to you
about that but it was kind of a off
topic though Cal Newport who you've had
on your show who's a really good friend
of mine and he wrote digital minimalism
all about being off social media has
like a really big TED talk about it he's
gonna come on the show as well he texted
me and he was like hey man I really like
that Dave Rubin interview you know I've
never heard him like talk about personal
stuff like that and I go oh cool man
yeah I got like I was like a lot of
people liked it but I got a lot of [ __ ]
from the left for even having him on and
I swear to God cow goes people don't
like Dave Rubin and I was like oh what a
magical world you live in to like not
have any [ __ ] idea like you can just
listen to an interview and be like that
guy sounded nice without knowing like
the
years of baggage and like weird inter
personality feuds and I just I wanted
that like in that moment I wanted to get
off Twitter forever that's interesting
yeah I mean as far as you know one can
be you know I think that one of the
great things that often happens when you
meet people in person that you are often
dealing with in different ways online is
that it almost never even remotely
resembles the online interactions and I
think that a lot of luck troll culture
and Internet trolling just would not
happen it would immediately evaporate if
more people met in person for the most
part like 98% of it because in-person
people are for the most part not going
to treat each other the way that they do
on the Internet and you know putting
aside any particular like political
disagreements or critiques that I've had
of Dave Rubin or getting into the things
he said about me or whatever I mean I
think that in general we would just be
so much better off if there was more
in-person interaction although I
understand why some people are skeptical
of it because there are dangerous and
crazy people out there and you don't
necessarily want to be interacting with
those people on a regular basis someone
I've literally had no one ever
negatively confront me in real life even
people who disagreed the conversation
was pretty [ __ ] bailout um
yeah I think in real life for the most
part my experience isn't pretty similar
yeah yeah so well let's just talk about
let's talk about Reuben because I got I
definitely got [ __ ] for having him on
from people who didn't listen to the
show I don't know the personal drama
between you and him or I see like I see
like cedar going at because I'm still
like I still talk to Sam I still like
cedar going after him all the time
and the what I tried to do and I think
the reason people liked the interview
was I did just want to talk about
personal stuff and I wanted to you know
if he said something I disagreed with so
he he doesn't agree with the $15 minimum
wage instead of me just like shouting my
talking points into his mouth
was kind of like why do you think that
and what do you think we should do for
you know the single mother who has to
work two jobs like looking for a
solution right but a lot of people were
like well you should have countered him
more so what I would love to talk to you
about you identify as a capitalist I
believe which is something that again is
kind of like frowned upon on some parts
of the left what's your take on the
minimum wage on you know balancing
capitalism with social programs what do
you think the best approach for making
people that may be successful people
aren't punished but also that we don't
have these horrifying statistics of
people who can barely get by and feed
their kids well one thing I think it's
important just to mention is when you
know capitalism is such a broad category
that it encompasses so many different
pilote about the political ideology so I
consider myself a social democrat which
means there's still private ownership of
business they're still you know taking
profit is okay etc but I think that
taxation should be used in order to fund
government programs that make sure
nobody is sort of like falling too far
down and that we establish a minimum
quality of life for everybody so it's
really important to say when you say I'm
a capitalist that's correct but I want
to make sure it's not i'm not a lazy
fair no regulation libertarian sort of
vulture capitalist and there's a
difference between those things yeah
when i was like sue when i was on that
side of the left any time someone said a
capitalist
I literally just pictured like mr. Bern
shutting off Springfield's power like
every time and then I remember the first
time the first time I was like I think
the left's gone too far
was there was an article I don't know if
you remember this but there was an
article written it was like an expose
about Amy Goodman the host of democracy
now and they were like Amy Goodman makes
five hundred thousand dollars a year or
like something like that
like while claiming she's won
vas and I was like [ __ ] Amy
Goodman has been like attacked by rebel
troops overseas I want her to be a
bazillionaire
like I want any Goodman to be so rich
and I think that's the part I think
that's the caricature that Republicans
think a lot of Democrats are where they
just like don't want anyone to be
successful and then I think a lot of
Democrats think that or a lot of
liberals think that all capitalists are
these money hungry monsters who want you
know billionaires to pay no taxes while
poor people struggle to get food yeah I
mean I think first of all there would be
a lot of people who would be very
surprised by what all sorts of people on
the Left make personally and I think
that yeah I don't really know anything
about Amy Goodman I've been on her
program once and I don't really watch
any shows so I couldn't tell you
anything that's happened on her program
for who knows how many years so I
couldn't tell you what her economic
views are or anything but I think that
there are many people in all of our
audiences who would be extremely
surprised by what some of some of the
shows on the left-hand right make so
that's number one I think there is
something a little bit unfair about
singling out a show I think this is sort
of like when people talk about hey
Bernie's a millionaire so is he really
the man of the people that people that
he claims to be in his supporters claim
that he is what's his policy right I
mean like how much money he personally
has is less important and what policy
would key enact and if he would enact
policies that would be good for the
lower class in the middle class and
people who are sort of disadvantaged by
some of the structural economic
inequality that exists then what does it
matter if he has 1.1 or 1.3 million
dollars mostly from this book that he
wrote a few years ago and I think that
that's sort of the fundamental problem
with those personal arguments yeah and I
also think a lot of times again with
Twitter it turns into gossip it turns
into when you run out of things everyone
kind of wants to be the cool kid you
know they kind of want to be like neo
from the matrix who's like oh you're
offended by this well I'm offended by
this times whatever like there's nothing
more edgy than to go after Amy Goodman
who supposedly is like the most
progessive hosts on the left and I think
that's when that's when the kind of
liberal Twitter media it goes from
talking about ideas to just toxic gossip
it's just oh we we think of it as a
higher form of gossip because it's more
it's more intellectual or whatever you
know something happened that similar I
don't remember exactly where with Noam
Chomsky and against and whatever you
think about Noam Chomsky I don't know
how old he is he's very close to 90
years old yes and there was an article
about hey Noam Chomsky has a couple
million bucks and he also has money part
in mutual funds that you know are really
broad index funds so they have little
pieces of oil companies and whatnot I
mean listen he's almost 90 years old two
million dollars at that point is not
crazy for someone who's been at the top
level of academia for as long as he's
been at the top level of academia I
agree with him on some things but I just
don't understand it you know it doesn't
it's not an argument against any of his
political positions to point out that he
has mutual funds you know what I mean
right it's one of those like gotcha
moments so what what is your what is
your sort of balance what are the what
are the sort of pros of capitalism you
see the pros of more of a Bernie Sanders
of more social democratic socialist are
there conversations to be had between
the right and the left when it comes to
this cuz again I think a lot of
conservatives thinks that socialism
means that we're all going to be working
in the fields and a lot of people on the
Left think that capitalism means that
poor people are just [ __ ] as the rich
get richer what's your ideal balance
I mean you first of all you can't even
dig into that until you start to get on
equal footing as to what these terms
even mean so way too often people say we
don't want to be socialists like in
Scandinavia and every single one of
those countries is a capitalist country
and when we talk about you know as you
say they're working in the field sort of
idea in countries that
really depend on agriculture what fields
are there for people to even work in I
mean it's just such a silly meme and
it's a good thing to get those out in
the open and figure out what we are
talking about and what we're not talking
about my fundamental view is that in
modern day earth when you look at the
countries that are doing the best in a
few different ways if we look at per
capita income if we look at
self-reported happiness if you look at
crime and inequality what the tendency
is is that the countries that are
capitalist countries in the sense that
people can get very wealthy there's
private ownership of business etc but
those countries decide that the
priorities of taxation are going to be
to make sure people have access to
health care to ensure that nobody goes
below a certain standard of living those
are the countries that in total balance
are doing the best and that's kind of my
starting point for the model that we
should be following so what are we
missing from that right now well there's
a few different things often immediately
the right will say well we would have to
raise taxes outrageously to be able to
do any of the things that those
countries do and that's not really true
I mean a lot of it is just priorities
and when you look at defense spending
when you look at the extraordinarily
inefficient ways that a lot of our
systems sort of just burn money
including the health insurance health
care system and so many others a lot of
it is just saying we need to have some
different priorities we don't
necessarily need 50 military bases in
Germany you might be too safe with 20
and then what those other 30 costs could
actually be reallocated so I think the
wrong conversation is the one of how
much the taxes have to go up that means
said there are many proposals that
without changing anything about the
defense industrial complex with very
small increases to taxes on employers
and employees you can do a lot of things
that would be really stimulative to the
economy you know when you look at a
program to provide health care to
everybody and there's medicare for all
in a lot of other
as well yes you can do it with a small
increase in taxes on employees and
employers but what's often just
completely missing from that
conversation is on the other side of the
ledger there's no more premiums there's
no more employers paying for sometimes a
third or half or two-thirds of someone's
health insurance premium there's no more
co-pays yes you're adding something but
you're also taking something away so I
feel like when when the conversation
starts at how can we ever afford that
we're already missing the boat
completely that's what a lot of other
countries just understand inherently
what's really a point and I think that's
kind of why I opened up with talking
about having conservatives listening to
to both of us or at least being open to
it because I think there's just a lot of
misconceptions out there you know I
remember covering Occupy Wall Street
really heavily and a lot of people I
talked to thought that they were part of
the 1%
and it's like no like when I was a small
business owner when I had my most money
I definitely got to that point when I
got my first tax bill where I was like
oh this is why people are Republicans
whatever happening is those small
business owners who aren't super wealthy
but are doing well they are getting
[ __ ] over a lot and those taxes are
going to a lot of things they would
disagree with I think what people don't
understand is for the most part when we
say or at least when I say the 1% I'm
not even talking about the people you
see in first class like [ __ ] I
get in first class cuz I got miles like
I'm talking about the people who have
their own planes who well that's
actually much higher than the I think
it's important to distinguish you know
the 1% I think is around $400,000 a year
in income ok and I think you know
changes every year but roughly that's
what we're talking about so sure we can
talk about the 1% but where you really
start to see extremely disproportion
when you talk about like the 0.2 percent
and the 0.1 percent
and the point zero zero five percent and
that's you know when you when you chart
that out visually for people they are
shocked there some really interesting
data from I believe it's the Pew
Research Center where they accepted
people is tell us how you think the
quintiles of income are divided in other
words if you split up the population
into twenty percent groups the lowest 20
percent 20 to 40 40 to 60 60 to 80 and
80 to 100 and people just draw it draw
lines the country as a whole drastically
by orders of magnitude underestimates
the degree of inequality that exists at
that top within that top 20 percent and
it's like if we don't even have an
understanding of what the income
distribution is we're not going to be
able to have productive conversations
about what the laws should be and how
taxation should work because we don't
even know what's going on in our own
country right well the other thing I
wanted to bring up kind of along that
same line when you were talking about
health care is before before I when I
like refused to engage with
conservatives I pretty much thought that
if you didn't want some kind of
universal health care your health care
plan was like I want kids to die like I
want people to die and after talking to
conservatives much like you were saying
that you don't agree with a lot of the
ways our tax dollars are spent a lot of
conservatives go might even think our
health care system is broken or at least
they go
my family's okay I don't trust the
government because I don't like the way
the government you know you always hear
like the DMV or the post office or
whatever like do you want your health
care being run this way so what's your
response to that where when people maybe
they're not acting in bad faith maybe
they you know really do think that what
we have now is is the best for their
families for other families and that the
government like they have many other
things are just gonna [ __ ] it up I mean
listen if you look at satisfaction
surveys with health care you don't even
really have
to argue with the people that are really
thrilled with the way healthcare works
because so few people are thrilled with
the way health care works there's no
question I mean I think the bigger issue
which you're kind of alluding to is this
issue of who deserves what in this
country and you can agree that the
system is broken which I think look
you've said a lot of people on the right
agree but in the end there is no it's
much more difficult to convince someone
that we are all better off even if
people who don't quote deserve health
care still get it if it's an issue of
morality and ethics for them I mean I
think I'm Joe Rogan's program I called
it's strict father morality make sure
you can show people the economic sense
of replacing the system we have with a
system like that in many other European
countries where you get equal or better
access equal or better outcomes for
significantly less money but you can't
convince them that it's okay for someone
that doesn't work or can't afford the
care currently to just get it because
that goes through a much deeper sort of
moral and ethical framework that many
conservatives have and I generally don't
know actually how to argue against that
because it's in many cases just so
deeply ingrained yeah I mean I think
there are a lot of people who
legitimately think and I I'm told there
are studies that show that you know with
a certain amount of handouts or you know
access to free this or that health care
education which I believe are basic
rights it doesn't incentivize people to
work you know if you keep giving them
food stamps they're never gonna go get a
job if you keep giving them welfare
they're never gonna go get a job etc etc
and I don't agree with them yeah I will
say however in my personal life when I
started when I sort of stopped hanging
out with just like liberal journalists
and I threw myself into MMA and was just
hanging out with athletes and did have
more of that pull yourself up by your
bootstraps mentality which I think a lot
of conservatives were maybe
raised a little more with it did help my
personal life but at the same time I'm a
white guy who grew up middle-class and
like I've had my struggles and and and
so forth but I also didn't start with
both hand side behind my back
yeah I mean so let's see the problem is
a lot of people can't even afford the
bootstraps by which they could
conceivably pull themselves up and then
the question is what do you do about
that so there's actually a lot of
studies about welfare programs as a
disincentive and here's the thing I
actually think that the art the
conversation around people who will be
disincentivized
to be quote productive members of
society by welfare programs is not the
right conversation because if you go
back to any social welfare program there
will always be what's called the free
rider problem and the question is do the
Free Riders justify not having a program
altogether whose net benefit is
abundantly clear so I'll give you an
example if you think of food stamps
which by the way is a terrible example
because food stamps it's such a small
amount of money per month and it's also
so economically stimulated because the
money goes right back into local
businesses mostly grocery stores but
let's let's play out the food stamps
example sure imagine that there is some
percentage of people receiving food
stamps that because of those food stamps
aren't even going to try to get a job
because I mean I guess they don't need
money for rent or to buy anything else
but they're happy with their food stamps
and that's gonna disincentivize just
like for tomato ramen noodle packages
and that's how they live right I mean
it's like it's so absurd that we're
having a hard time even framing up a way
to discuss this but imagine those people
exist the total economic benefit of the
food stamp program because the money
goes right back into local businesses
combined with the fact that kids that
are hungry in school don't learn nearly
as well making them not get good grades
making them eventually not productive
members of society by this definition
that we're kind of agreeing
who cares about some tiny percentage of
people who are living the life on food
stamps and choosing not to work the
overall economic benefit over the long
term of the program is so huge that why
are we even consuming any space in our
minds with that small percentage of Free
Riders and the thing is any social
welfare system will have some Free
Riders but if it's well constructed that
is a percentage that we can predict
ahead of time and does not derail the
utility of the program do you think that
part of the reason that conservatives
are so skeptical liberal programs is
because we've never at least recently
had like a truly but let me use a
Obamacare for an example I think that I
almost think that Medicare for all would
it even though it was framed as being
infinitely more extreme than Obamacare I
think in the long run it would have
gotten much more support because even
though Obamacare did a lot of good
things like get rid of pre-existing
conditions and allow people to stay on
their parents health care longer like
for me personally that was another
moment where I saw my health insurance
bill under Obamacare was like I guess I
become Republican where I was like you
so a couple thing you've got to remember
that all healthcare premiums all health
insurance premiums were gumming up
inside of the Obamacare exchanges and
outside so it's a really poor argument
to say Obamacare was bad because
Obamacare exchange plans got more
expensive because they got more
expensive at a slower rate than the non
Obamacare plans this is a bigger problem
health care premiums have been going up
for decades
myname criticism of Obamacare is it's
fundamentally a corporatist center-right
program and in fact it was actually
originally conceived by the conservative
Heritage Foundation during the 1990s
because think about fundamentally what
it does it says you must go and get a
health care plan from a for-profit
insurers right young dates at health
care companies
that make money off of people's health
health problems that is get tens of
millions of new customers so I agree
with you that satisfaction with Medicare
for all would have been much higher than
with Obamacare I think there is no way
that when Obamacare was passed in 2010
Medicare for all would have passed but I
do believe that it's a much better
program that people would be far more
satisfied with yeah I was Pro Obamacare
I want to Medicare for all but I was
like this will be a stepping stone you
know I mean I wish Obama opened with
wanting to Medicare for all instead of
opening with the compromise you know
which I feel like a lot of liberals
wanted but I my greater point was I
think there are a lot of I think there
are a lot of liberal policies that
conservatives or centrist or
libertarians assume we've tried when we
really haven't liked Obamacare isn't
anywhere near everyone having free
health care and I think if suddenly
Republicans woke up and had free health
care and had access to good doctors and
we did it correctly the be like oh holy
[ __ ] I think part of our problem is
because we have so many corporatist
Democrats and I mean corporate Democrats
and Republicans who care more about
profit for their donors we haven't
really experienced a lot of these social
programs to their fullest of course and
that's why we have to look at the
countries that do have them and then
what you do I mean there's just no
question at all about it it's it's so
cut and dry almost any of the different
systems that you know the UK has a
different system from Canada which is
different from Germany which is
different from Switzerland and very
different than Sweden in Norway all of
those programs have some issues that we
can find but they all increase access
while reducing costs relative to our
system yeah and if we actually cared
about people we could Bruce Lee that
[ __ ] and like take what we like and
disregard what we don't and we could be
innovators again we could be capitalists
we could be competitive and we could
take the best from all those systems
and create our own no question about it
and in fact wendell potter who's a
former health care health insurance
company executive for Cigna he writes in
this book deadly spin about how I
believe it's just after World War one
and before World War two the US was
rapidly heading in the direction of a
system that would have been very much
like the one that Germany has but
because at the time things were not
going so well in the relationship
between the US and Germany
the idea was basically abandoned because
oh that's too much like what the Germans
are doing and it led to the early stages
of the system we have now which we've
not been able to get away from kind of
on the same level I have not been
following the the most recent free
college education debate just cuz we're
in the process of moving ahead of Los
Angeles where are you on that well I
think that there is a very interesting
idea in saying that we're not talking
about all college what we're talking
about state colleges and universities
being tuition free for people who get in
right away I can tell you you said like
four things I have not heard in the
conversation when it's the extreme side
just yelling at each other I mean nobody
is saying anybody who wants to go to
Harvard goes to Harvard just by signing
up what we're saying is if every even
state schools have admission
requirements and some of them are very
difficult and if you are accepted to one
of these schools you would be able to go
to ition free I think that the economic
argument is a pretty straightforward one
which is that there are huge economic
negatives to people students being
saddled with the absurd student loan
debt that they currently have it makes
them it forces them into making
decisions that are not the right
decisions for them in terms of career
choices merely because they've got a
student loan payment that's coming
that's not good for society to have
people working jobs they don't really
want to work it makes them have to spend
money on interest paid to huge lenders
rather than spending that money in the
local communities which is much more
economically simulative so I totally get
the economic idea behind it I think that
it's more a question of political
viability and political will and also
it's okay that not everybody should go
to college like I've had this
conversation with presidential candidate
Andrea and I had this conversation with
Joe Rogan I'm not about make everyone go
to college I can't deny that we are
increasingly in the United States not
competitive in science and math with
many other countries that at some point
is going to have to be dealt with one
way or the other and technological
automation is going to impact that we
can have all those conversations it's
okay that not everybody is cut out for
college and we should also be figuring
out how to support people working in
trades and other areas bearing in mind
that many of those jobs are open to or
liable to be automated away in the next
15 years right like if I so I dropped
out of high school and when I talked to
my dad about going to college well the
first thing is this was an actual thing
I remember my dad was like what if
comedy falls through you need a back-up
plan
and I very earnestly said I have a
back-up plan dad I plan a band so I
wasn't exactly like the most
level-headed kid in the world but what I
did say that finally convinced him if I
went to college even if I went to
college for music but if I just went
because I thought I was supposed to go I
would have ended up being an alcoholic
riddled in debt instead I got to start
stand-up at 17 I got a head start or
even a worse example and I'm just I'm
excited that you brought this up because
I don't hear it talked about often but a
worst example is the drummer in my band
was like the most talented drummer on
the [ __ ] planet and I thought he was
gonna like hit the road with me his
parents wanted him to go to college he
couldn't afford college so he joined the
military this was pre September 11th
joined the military so he could get into
college
then the war in Iraq starts he goes over
to the war in Iraq started [ __ ]
drinking heavily bla bla bla comes
back and just wants to play drums but
now it's 8 years later with a drinking
problem after seeing his friends die
just because we're kind of told that you
have to go to college to be successful
yeah and I think that that's something
that is ingrained pretty early for a lot
of people and the truth is that in many
fields you do have to go to college in
order to be successful but the point is
we yeah I think if we even zoom out from
this a little bit
things are changing significantly in the
world of employment and just the
relationship of humans to work and as
without being a technological dystopian
and imagining that every job is going to
get automated away in the next five
years there are many jobs which are
going to be superfluous or unnecessary
as a result of Technology and bigger
picture at some point they're gonna have
to be an accounting of what should the
relationship of humans in particularly
rich Western countries like the United
States to this idea of having to work 40
hours in a regular job in order to
support yourself no candidate is really
talking about that right Jesus yeah all
right totally switching gears I was
listening to I haven't heard your most
recent episode but I was listening to
your episode on Iran I think you put it
out on Sunday let's talk about that or
we gotta [ __ ] go to war with Iran
does anybody want war in Iran that's not
these like old Hawks that are in the
Trump administration how do you see this
playing out what the [ __ ] is happening I
hope that we don't go to war with Iran
one interesting thing is that Donald
Trump will often use very aggressive
rhetoric with a lot of different
countries North Korea as an example
Syria Venezuela Iran and so far in the
end he's basically backed away from
action with Iran most recently it was
like at the very last second after he
had already approved a strike and the
interesting thing about this and this is
not
any kind of like Putin and Trump are
talking every day about exactly what it
is that Donald Trump is supposed to do
but it's in the end Donald Trump sort of
ends up going with the position or the
action or usually it's a lack of action
which does protect Russia's interests
and what Vladimir Putin would prefer so
that applies to Syria the bombing of
that empty runway which was back up and
running within hours this applies to
looking super interested at going into
the news whele during the winter and
then backing away from that not long
after he had a conversation with
Vladimir Putin in early May and we don't
know what role russia's interests may
have played in the decision to not go
forward with the strug in iran but if
that history which now we have a couple
of years of tells us anything it
suggests alternately Donald Trump is not
going to start a war in Iran which would
go directly counter to Russia's
interests well you were also kind of
talking about on your show how this was
kind of like what he did in business
like he's sort of just like talked a
bunch of [ __ ] to try to scare people
right there was a lot of that there was
threaten you know threats of lawsuits
there were I think also actual lawsuits
and Michael Cohen his former personal
attorney who's now in prison talked
about this a lot talking about this for
the investigators talked about this when
he testified under oath before a House
Committee I believe it was although it
may have been the Senate so this is
basically the political version of the
way Donald Trump has run his businesses
his entire life he's just now taking it
from you know whoever's doing the
windows at his latest real estate
project that he's negotiating with and
threatening with lawsuits to other
countries world leaders and geopolitics
right you said something else I wanted
to talk about on that episode where a
lot of people who criticize the worst
aspects of Islam are oftentimes just
lumped into your right-wing islamaphobe
right and I think what happens is when
we lump them in with the right-wing
Islamophobes and we don't give them a
home on the Left they start seeking out
people who agree with them and
oftentimes those
people solution is military intervention
and then as we know military
intervention oftentimes embolden
extremists and is incredibly
counterproductive yeah that's I mean I
actually don't remember addressing that
particular element in the Iran peace but
it's something that I definitely
addressed many times before which is we
need to be able to sort of understand
that in the same way that we can
criticize ideas that came from
Christianity for example without them
being criticisms of all Christians or
all Christian sects it's got to be ok to
apply the same sort of logic or critical
thinking or criticism to any religion
Islam being one of those I think that
this is a really difficult gray area
because there is a ton of bad faith
argumentation here there there are
people who will claim that they are just
criticizing ideas but they are doing it
in a way really to demonize Muslims as
people and there are others who are not
doing that and many of them are on the
left so I think it's really important to
understand especially in this era of
echo chambers and filter bubbles that
exist on the Internet and these
algorithms that are recommending often
very extreme content if we don't I say
we if I don't if someone decidedly on
the left make clear that no ideas are
sort of off-limits from criticism as
long as we're being thoughtful and
talking about it in good faith people
who would otherwise remain squarely on
my side are going to get sucked into
these right wing echo chambers and we
know that it happens because some of
them explain how it's happened to them
right well where I was going that you
did cover on your episode is I think
that when you end up in that extreme on
that extreme side you think the only
answer is military right is to go to war
but you pointed out on your episode
which I didn't even put together that
talked about how by Trump pulling out
the the deal with Iran that actually is
what gave cave Iran permission to do the
thing that we threatened to attack them
for what about Barack Obama signed this
Iran nuclear deal with Iran and there
were people who opposed it at the time
and even people who were generally in
favor of it might have opposed specific
provisions but the word of a president
especially when you sign off on it has
to be worth something really significant
if we are going to be dealt with as
credible negotiators but when we're
talking to other countries so for Donald
Trump to come in and say okay we're the
u.s. is just out even though Iran hadn't
violated any aspect of the Iran deal
even if you think that Iran is a bad
actor even if you think that Iran has
bad intentions you really are doing a
lot of self-inflicted damage when you
just unilaterally say even though you've
done nothing wrong I'm getting or I'm
getting us out of the deal and if you're
Iran who I don't want to see you get
nuclear weapons of course you started
enriching uranium right away if your
intentions are to use it for nuclear
power then there's a very clear
incentive to start the research as soon
as possible if your intentions are to
use it to develop nuclear weapons we
know historically that having those
nuclear weapons for other countries has
been a valuable negotiating tool and
countries that have given them up have
I'm going to ended up in in worse
situations so Donald Trump precipitated
Iran doing the obviously predictable
thing and then he's using that as a
justification to further threaten
escalation what do they you know with
Iraq we talked about oil what are they
besides like waving their dicks around
what is their the John Bolton's Donald
Trump what do they get out of a war with
Iran there's two sides to that there so
there's the financial
military-industrial complex side and
then there's also the sort of neocon
spread democracy side of this in
thing and those two sides often overlap
we saw them overlap significantly with
the 2003 Iraq war where you had a huge
military industrial complex
profit-driven side but then you also had
the idea of let's go back in and finish
the job that wasn't done under George HW
Bush which was more sort of like the
ideological side so it's a combination
of both there's also more complicated
you know politics involved relating to
Saudi Arabia for example and so it's
multifaceted and for Trump I don't even
know how much he knows about all of that
stuff I mean I really do think that
could Trump a lot of this from what we
hear from insiders is he just gets the
idea of something that sounds
interesting to make him look powerful
and alpha and then when it gets
complicated you just sort of gets bored
with it and loses patience and sometimes
moving moves on I don't know how much
pump is even aware of all of these
underlying elements houses parents got
divorced and just like driving around
like a lunatic with like all the new
toys and then throwing them away it's
but then at the same time having these
longtime hawks in his administration who
have been pushing for war and I also
like I want to say because I mean I I
guess I have talked about war a bunch on
this news show but just because there
are military people and conservative
people who listen to me
I think a lot of liberals who are
anti-war are categorized as he's sort of
like anti true [ __ ] but for me and I
would assume for you one of the reasons
that I'm against these wars is because I
don't want [ __ ] troops to die for a
bunch of these elite [ __ ] I think
that is a very Pro troop stance to not
want to send them over to another
[ __ ] war of course I don't I am in
favor of listen we don't have a draft
because our volunteer military is is
large enough and in fact if we sucked a
lot of these pointless military
engagements it would be more than large
enough by many orders of magnitude the
only reason we even need or having these
for as many troops as are currently the
military is because of all the
engagements together so I believe that
it is
obviously pro-military to say it we
can't just say that military action is
is a last resort or the the final option
on the table it actually has to be
reflected in our foreign policy we can't
just say support the troops but you
actually have to make sure that the
troops have adequate health care when
they get back I just read today that
Donald Trump said some troops just
aren't strong enough to deal with PTSD
which is just so horrible and toxic if
Obama said that he would have been
kicked out of office and imprisoned
right absolutely and so so I do support
the troops in a way that is is best for
them rather than best for the sort of
neoconservative political ideology of
the right which sees troops basically as
pawns to be used in their chess game
okay so last question actually two more
quick questions you talked about this a
lot on Rogen the steven crowder YouTube
algorithm I agreed with you and I agreed
with Rogen your face started to go viral
when Joe Rogan was like steven crowder
is a comedian and you looked a ghast to
say the least that he's a comedian I
think you can say that you know that was
definitely not like a good faith
George Carlin asked subversive joke and
steven crowder was being a bit
homophobic and also not be psyched to
have algorithms d monetizing people on
YouTube you know right after that
happened we started to see progressive
journalists who have done investigative
work on white supremacy get D monetized
just because white supremacists came up
in the algorithm and then I only saw
briefly that you had a video demonetized
I don't know why a very popular video do
you think that even though YouTube is a
private corporation that the D
monetization that D platforming do you
think that that's dangerous or are you
kind of on the side of like look if
you're gonna be a homophobic [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out and if there are
consequences you know
even if they affect you personally so be
it well there's there's two things here
it's really important to separate the
monetization from deep platforming if
content isn't illegal or violating
YouTube's Terms and Conditions in terms
of bullying or violence they're they're
not deep platforming someone by de
monetizing them now that being said for
me the real problem here is not the D
monetization of homophobic targeting of
a journalist okay that is not the
problem the problem for me is what goes
beyond left or right and which I've been
experiencing this week which is that
anything that touches remotely
controversial topics even in an FCC safe
way like for example my coverage of
what's going on with Iran is because of
YouTube's Pro profit bias that's the
real bias yeah it's being demonetised
out of an abundance of caution and it's
hurting I am uniquely positioned in the
sense that my channel is big enough that
I actually do depend on it to pay my
employees but it's not so big that we
have you know we're not in the CNN
position so to speak so channels like
mine are at real risk when an algorithm
says anything that's remotely
controversial in this way we just won't
monetize because it's affecting channels
at my level disproportionately right do
you think that because I've said this
before when it comes to talk about fake
news like being biased or who's being
the platform is I think a lot of it just
has to do with [ __ ] money where the
news covered Trump at the news didn't
cover Trump that much during the
campaign and covered Bernie equally I
don't think Trump would have won but now
it does look like there's a liberal bias
cuz now the popular thing is you know go
after Trump I think that the bottom line
is
corporations just want a profit I don't
really know if there is a left or right
agenda when it comes to YouTube when it
comes to 24-hour news and so on well
it's important to distinguish editorial
decisions and sort of structural bias so
as an example I think there's no
question that you can argue that YouTube
has a progressive leaning internal
culture but question when it comes to
the D monetization is what is the motive
there and for me there's every
indication that it's just keeping
advertisers happy if it's regulating
content that's concerning to advertisers
or left-wing content or just
controversial content that's what
they're going to target so that they can
tell advertisers don't worry your your
abs won't appear on that stuff with Fox
News to give a different example of
types of bias Fox News of course
editorially is right-wing but they're
not necessarily pro Trump I mean they
have been programmed for the last couple
of years but remember at the beginning
of the 2016 Republican primary Fox News
was not Pro Trump in it not Trump and
Fox News were really butting heads
eventually Fox made the business
decision that they were going to jump on
the Trump train and then again depending
on how the next six months ago Fox News
will continue being right-wing but they
won't necessarily continue being Pro
Trump oh right and then let's take the
other extreme to how people say that
MSNBC is the left-wing equivalent of Fox
News it's like number one we have like
23 hours of [ __ ] Joe Scarborough
number two they forget that after
September 11th the only anti-war voices
were fired from MSNBC for that same
reason Fox News was taking off in the
ratings with American flags [ __ ] yeah
America and then we had Phil Donahue on
MSNBC being like maybe we should go to
Iraq and they [ __ ] fired him so like
how left-wing is that yeah no question
about it and ultimately it's I mean yes
editorially MSNBC has what you would
call like a sort of establishment
Democrat center-left stance but at its
core it is a big corporate media outlet
controlled by a huge company just like
Fox News and I think that that's what
people often miss when they just say
well you know Chris Matthews seems sort
of left and it's sort of the same as
Tucker being right-wing on Fox News
there are ways in which it's similar and
there are ways in which the dynamic
very different yeah alright last
question this is just for me as dummy
high school dropout becoming a new fan
of yours how [ __ ] much do you read you
are one of the most intelligent people
I've ever talked to you and I have so
much trouble retaining this much I
legitimately not hyperbolically not
trying to be funny what how much reading
goes into your your prep for the show
and just to have because god damn dude
you are like really well-versed in
everything Thanks well which is why I
try rather you know I do read news but I
really only read news when I'm
specifically preparing for a specific
episode of the show otherwise I barely
watch any TV news and I don't really
watch any other news and politics on
YouTube other than stuff I'm critiquing
or talking about and I try to mostly
read a lot of nonfiction whether it's
science philosophy sociology psychology
because I feel like that stuff is like
the foundation of the pyramid that lets
me analyze the other stuff so I try to
focus more on that type of reading than
keeping up with every bit of news oh I
love that so kind of like you know why
they say you're supposed to go to
college to like learn how to think
you're not necessarily reading like
every brand new political book on the
new sort of controversy of the day but
you'd rather read philosophy and just
sharpen your brain so when you do attack
those issues you're kind of more
prepared yeah I mean I don't read any
political books I maybe read like three
political books a year I'm kind of think
the last one I read it might've I don't
even remember what it was but I'm
reading is right now I'm reading like
life 3.0 by Max tegmark which is about
artificial intelligence how we're going
to be prepared prepared for that I
recently read Guns Germs and Steel by
Jared Diamond which was a very
interesting book about how different
populations did well and not so well in
human history and this stuff I just see
is kind of like the founder
to really even be able to understand the
news do you ever catch yourself because
I debate sometimes when I'm getting
stories because I don't you know what
I'm doing a lot of stand-up I don't
watch stand-up I'm kind of the same with
you I don't you know want to watch new
shows or other personalities you know as
much just because I don't want to be
influenced but I still do find myself I
wonder you know alright what's the best
way to get stories do I go to CNN the
intercept and Colet and try to grab a
bunch of different types or do I go to
Twitter to see what everyone's talking
about because I don't want to get sucked
into 24-hour news I'm sure I'll watch
the [ __ ] debates just because I have
to but how do you how do you kind of
gather your stories do you have go to
sites do you want to see what people are
talking about so you can give your take
yeah I have a very limited list of
people I follow on Twitter which I will
take a glance at what's being discussed
and a lot of them are just sort of like
a newsfeed so I can get a sense of what
is what is happening and then I have
like a private multi Reddit with some
very nice news related and politics
related subreddits that are good sources
to see what certain enclaves in the
political world are talking about and
you know I'm only doing six stories a
day so from all of that stuff there's
always six things to talk about well
back when you're a [ __ ] nerd but I
admire the [ __ ] out of that that's
awesome that's really really cool well
listen man I really hope that listeners
of the show
check you out I hope the more
conservative ones check you out I really
really enjoy it and I I just appreciate
you coming on man it was cool to finally
finally talk absolutely really
appreciate you having me on anything I
promoted the podcast but I totally fried
your YouTube channel is kind of what
you're known for
besides the podcast what do you want to
promote yeah just david packing.com has
the audio and the video and the podcast
feed and all of that stuff so that's the
best place to follow the show okay cool
and then we're on patreon
this podcast is but you are you also
have a program to support your contents
free but you have a program on your
website to support your show as well
correct it's like six dollars a month or
something that's right join pakman.com
takes you directly to the membership
sign up wishes it's our number one
funding source and you know thanks to
the growth in those paid subscribers
were at least slightly insulated from
the YouTube D monetization stuff it
still does affect us but a little bit
less than it would if we didn't have
that membership program in place I'm
totally taking that as inspiration for
our podcast as we build it up it's cool
to see someone who talks as freely as
you do doing so well and supporting
yourself and a staff so keep it up man
and I've you ever need anything reach
out thank you really appreciate it all
right thanks better oh my god what a
little smartypants ah guys go follow
david pacman he's on Twitter Instagram
YouTube iTunes and the show website he
just promoted and once again if you
liked this show or if you disagreed with
the show but like the conversation and
you want to support more media like this
like the David Pakman show
to support our show you can go to
patreon.com/scishow same podcast we are
like oh 650 ish dollars away from
doubling the show episode every day
making it an hour so you'll get more
stories more political stories and also
being able to afford a new computer so
it doesn't shut down like it did today
and almost lose this interview no big
deal and also video equipment so the
YouTube channel can finally get up and
running we can buy lights and we can
start to video podcasts all of this at
as well but you can subscribe to you now
I saw have a channel from a YouTube
youtube.com slash Jaime Hills team
alright guys thank you so much
patreon episode will come sometime this
week as we move to Arizona
and for everybody else who's not a
patron we will see you with a new
episode on Monday so go outside and
don't be a dick